Abraham is with us in Florida hi Abraham
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey good
afternoon uh Dave
I'm 22 years old I work as a sales
associate and I recently started
listening to your show and I've become a
fanatic I mean I did I'm in a bit of a
debt situation and I just don't know how
to target it
okay what's your debt I am sixty three
thousand three hundred dollars in debt
and you're 20 years old 23 23
okay what's your sixty three thousand on
what kind of debt all right well I just
recently started listening to Joe so
Dona it's three car loans but it's a
little bit of a unique situation because
those three cars that I have one is
thirty three thousand the second is
eighteen thousand three hundred and then
the one which is personally mine is five
thousand dollars out of three two are
under me and my father who recently last
year after being unfaithful to my mother
left the household and so he left me as
the head of the household and so when
are you gonna sell the cars the problem
is that come on give me one second so I
could get my composure all right so it
was a little before I started listening
to your show and essentially getting
into the finances
personal finance so I was a little bit
ignorant as to how it worked out so I
did essentially lend him my credit so
that debt is partially mine but I can't
sell those cars because he's using them
for his small business he had a big
grand idea of opening up a small
business which he did and those are his
two primary vehicles for work which he
uses so he still paying them the problem
is they're not prompt payments and it's
just a matter of time before he defaults
on one and it basically snowballs into
what I'm not looking towards to
bankruptcy are you are you on the town
the title I am
well if I'm the cosign of the one of
them on the loan I understand that you
co-signed the loan are you on the title
are you the owner that I'm not aware of
you don't know I don't know okay Wow
okay this is not gonna go well Abraham I
figured but yeah so one of two things is
gonna happen your dad is gonna bankrupt
you or you're gonna have an ugly
confrontation with your dad to stop this
from happening mm-hmm all right so the
only other option he has offered which I
still want to go through with but it's
the only other I guess feasible option
out of the two vehicles you lsn't he
only uses one of them for his company
use and the other he actually and out to
somebody else that does transportation
jobs and essentially yeah tolls out the
payments of the second vehicle from that
person that he rents it out to his offer
was to refinance those two vehicles into
one payment and then just paying that
off as one vehicle as long as he takes
your name off the loan but that's not
what he's talking about
yeah that's the thing you know here's my
offer
here's my offer I'm your 23 year old son
you should quit screwing me you should
sell these cars immediately instead of
taking advantage of your own son and
setting them up for bankruptcy so if you
and you need to find out if you're on
the title and if you're on the title you
need to see a lawyer and go pick the
cars up and sell them okay because
here's what's gonna happen
this guy's I'm sorry that your dad is a
skunk but your dad is a skunk yeah I'm
so sorry I mean it's hard it's a hard
thing to go through if you're 43 or
you're 23 or whatever three you are to
find out that your dad's a skunk but he
is and he's not a good man who would do
this to their own son after listening to
your show I'm
just to get my mom out of debt yeah um
she currently has a part-time and yeah
Nima my sister in the herd I've been
Abraham what city are you in Miami
Florida okay are you in a good church by
chance yeah I am my little sister is
actually well involved in our church I
just don't have time I'm juggling right
now I understand that wasn't what I was
asking I just I'm just trying to find
out what's going on in your life because
what I need you to do is I need you
holler at that pastor in that church and
sit down with him because you need a guy
that's that that's a got some more
experience to walk with you while you're
walking through one of the most
difficult things in your life and you
just need it you need a big brother
right now right yeah and I wish I was
there I could do it for you but that
this what I'm asking you to do at 23
years old is very difficult and you know
and it's very emotional and and your
family is going through a very very hard
time and so it's just gonna be good for
you to get some men in your corner that
have good values that can be there with
you and be strong with you and help you
to get the things done that you need to
do because you need to really figure out
what's going on with these cars and get
them sold but right it's gonna be a very
you know your dad is gonna have a fit
and all this kind of stuff and so you're
gonna have to have some people in your
corner that they got your back you know
nobody's got your back right now yeah I
do but I'm on the radio in Nashville so
I can't help a lot you know yeah I'm
cheering for you I want you to do it
because if you know if you if out of the
pain of your family separation and the
fear of your father's reaction if you do
nothing what were you and I both know is
he's not gonna pay the payment and
eventually the cars going to get repo'd
and eventually they're gonna force you
into bankruptcy you already told me that
mm-hmm so doing nothing is not a very
good plan I tried looking to the option
of actually selling on through Kelly
Blue Book I was able to get the value of
vehicles but that even if we sell it the
difference we would not be able to pay
back because uh right now what I have
saved up is just for my emergency fund
I've been looking at your baby steps who
are these cars financed with one is
financed through ally financial and the
other is blue Chrysler Capital so you've
got a high interest rate - that is
correct on one of them it's 11 percent
and the other I don't remember and every
month he has late payments so not only
is he paying interest is paying
penalties to and around your credit gets
worse well thankfully he hasn't gotten
to the point where it's past thirty days
late I always make sure that I met them
till the last couple days the paid on
time and he somehow manages but I'm
scared of the data I won't be able to
manage to make a payment and then that's
when it affects my credit yeah yeah
every time he's late every time he's
later to flex your credit that's what it
comes down correct so yeah yeah you you
need to holler at your past it's the
pastor of the church that your sisters
attending ask if you can sit down with
him and see if he can help you get
involved in your family situation and be
the person that walks with you and gives
you some extra strength of a good man
standing beside you while you make some
of these difficult decisions you'll have
to borrow the difference from your
credit union
I suspect you can probably do that to
cover the deficit but I would rather
these cars be gone your dad not be
responsible and you personally be
responsible for five or ten thousand
dollars of deficit then I would you be
you know we're talking about $50,000 in
debt here on two cars I've not thought
about that the credit union option you
know all right and and so and I'll tell
you what hold on and I'll have Kelly
pick up and see if we have a financial
coach in the area that can help you and
walk with you as well but you're just
you know you're just I'm asking you to
do a lot of really really tough stuff to
to face down your own father and that's
just hard to do man
and you know you got to really have some
people in your corner to go to ad that's
not okay you're screwing me here
screwing your own kid who does that and
you know some people do sad so hang on
Kelly I'll pick up and we'll get you
some help